on this week's show five top tips for
beginners getting into property
investments in the news we're going to
be discussing if Facebook are about to
jump on the property investment market
and we'll be answering all your
questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
I almost leads I'm Alistair Cunningham
and welcome to the property investors
podcast you feeling cold today yeah I'm
a little bit cold Mitchell a bit chilly
which we a bit a bit of a chill a little
bit happy I'm boiling man I'm like I
might so you've been up to man I ain't
seen you for a few days it's been now I
haven't asked you had the winner who has
the oh it's been amazing it's just been
incredible I've had the best couple of
days of my entire life so you had your
essay was cleaning day last week thing
yeah I did it's very good what do you
think that was good amazed I really
enjoyed it thank you man love that you I
appreciate it I didn't actually realize
you were that good at sales if you've
met me there surely you'd surely surely
surely you know yeah I didn't think you
thought about it that much I thought it
was just off the cuff but I didn't
realize it was such a system that you
want to place nothing is off the cuff
yeah no apart from off the cuff nobody
was really interested man comic clearly
we we am we learned all about the
winners sale system was really good it
is good as new it actually is very very
good I'm thinking to writing a book
about it but I to finish my other book
first yeah yeah once I finished reading
that at some point no let you know yeah
thanks man I appreciate it are we doing
this weekend did you promise I promise I
will read it there's a bun we can talk
about and make sure you'll have finished
it I'm not gonna say I'll finished it
but I'll definitely be reading it but
I'll but but you've got before more
yellow well yeah fine alright I'll be
that can you send it to me again cuz I
think I think that the reader
I didn't I didn't it's on my computer
I'm not used to this him me her all to
me that's wrong isn't it I think that's
a better way I think you I think it's
the wrong way around it feels wrong
doesn't feel right if this is weird
how much seats we should which this
should be the nasty say yeah whoever
sits in the seat can be nasty so you
stay where you are
yeah right first off this week's show 5
top tips to getting for beginners
getting into property so it's very
useful because so many as a lot of our
listeners are looking to get into
property so it's very useful so I mean
Simon talked about this very very
briefly on a video early this week so
we're gonna go into a little bit more
detail in but number one is realistic
goals
yeah realistic goals and expectations
interesting one yeah I I was running a
program of our Academy members recently
yes and this all goal-setting wasn't
part the programming is oh it was but
but I talked about goals and I was my
kind of my point was cuz I said I asked
someone a question I sort of said I told
to go and set goals for what they were
what they were gonna do and someone
stood up and they said they were gonna
do I can't wear it wasn't a but they
were gonna send 300 Lease Option as
there's massive stuff in the next 30
days that's what I'm gonna do
yeah and I was like cool what are you
gonna do in the 30 days after that and
they were like oh I don't know I was
like we gonna be able to do the same and
then why doing it that level this money
yeah and they were like well because I
want to get the route I was like I said
I told them that about a book called a
slight edge all the compound effects
similar to him in the book and basically
well I think they should be doing is
setting goals they can do every month
yeah realistic really it doesn't have to
be this massive action I I said so for
example who's better off the guy that
goes to the gym twice a week for five
years or the guy that goes every day for
two weeks and then gives up so it's you
wanna you wanna be able to set yourself
goals that you can actually achieve and
that's actually you've made a very good
point there about who's better that with
the gym analogy right we I see this a
lot on property people get in property
they say
they'll see France is this person
they'll send 300 letters and an asset
they won't do anything else yeah but
because they don't get results from the
funeral if they just say it doesn't work
yeah they need consistency so
realistically would be to send maybe 50
a month every month and the other thing
you know when you feel like you put any
masses of effort and don't get a return
really demotivating yeah but if you just
think and I said this them as well when
they set your goals you want to have a
picture of where you wanna be but you
the only thing you can control is the
actions so the actions are the stuff you
want to be tracking and then you just
trust that the results will follow so
your actions might be so the goal
shouldn't be I want to get four lease
option agreement no no that might be
your goal yeah but what you want to be
thinking about is what actions am I
gonna take in order to achieve that goal
did you just got a gonna get four lease
option to it that means I mean I think
it's meaningless yeah it comes down to
like I'm not going to criticize this but
like people have dream boards and things
that are the they have all these dream
boards which is great there's nothing
wrong with dream boards but you've got
to put in action to get to that dream
ball you need both it cannot just be you
look at a dream board every day of your
car you want or house you want you've
got to have realistic goals of how
you're gonna get there having said that
I agree having said that I do think that
things like dream boards have can be
very powerful yeah because the same I
don't want to go too deep right now on
goal-setting and stuff like that but if
if you have a Jim Carey for example when
he when he wanted to become an actor
yeah he used to he did like in his
wallet east carry on a piece of paper
and he set out what is his goals were
his dreams I want to be this I want to
be that I any any and he used to go to
the Hollywood Hills look at Hollywood
needs to read it and he used to believe
that was gonna I was gonna happen was
kind of like his dream board there's no
point having a dream board if it all it
is is a dream yeah but if you if you
select what you want to happen and you
believe that that's going to happen and
you do know you're right near the
actions in place as well but I do think
in a
belief in something is very very
powerful and if you think it's gonna
happen you've gotta believe before it
will happen when you've got believe that
whatever you're doing is going to work
if you don't believe it then it's not
gonna work it's simple as your thoughts
are unbelievably unbelievably powerful
yeah scientifically proven it's not like
Oh mind over matter but no I I agree
with you come on believable believe me
when you focus on negativity things when
you fought with negative do you think of
them expense when you for some negative
things and it's not gonna work
you're right doesn't matter how you
think about it you're right out of the
way if you believe it's gonna work it's
gonna work if believe it's not gonna
work again you're right
Henry Ford said that did you know
optimists you live a lot longer than
pessimists I wonder why it's because
they believe they're gonna live longer
perhaps true yeah it's brilliant
interesting when and we could talk about
this all took like this all day you talk
about your gold set in your boot I
probably if I this is the problem with
my book this is a problem in my book is
that when I'm learning so much all I
mean I'm not learning so much but I'm
tweaking I'm I am learning so much
continually reading studying learning
and then I'll go back to me I wrote it
six months ago and I'll be like that's
good I want to add to it and I
continually want to add to the book I'll
be like a ball about this what about
that so whatever I put on goal setting
in the book if I probably haven't
program it looks out for six months I
probably now if I looked it again
wouldn't change it probably all still
stands but I'd want to you add to it so
you've made me think now I'm gonna go
back I'm going to add to it because yeah
but with regards to realistic goals to
really see actions it's not it's a lot
in the slight edge or it'll come an
effect I get them confused as they're
very similar but like it's easy to do
yeah it's also easy not to do yeah but
you want to make it easy to do so for
example if you want if you wanted it's
easy to choose a healthy meal at a
restaurant yeah that's not a difficult
decision but it's also easy to order a
burger but when you're there that if you
just look at it as lots of little
actions all it's just lots and lots and
lots of little actions but it's about
discipline what would you say it are
realistic goals for a big
in a beginner investor to submit score
maybe a little bit of money in the bank
they're looking to getting probably what
would you see is a realistic goal well
the first thing that they need to work
out before they before they look at
their goals and I probably do talk about
this in the book is the difference
between your personal goals and your
business goals okay so the first thing
in before you set your business goals
before you go I want to get a lease
option agreement I wanna do this I will
do that why what do you actually want do
you want to work you've done this to me
before I have and it's late and you hate
it I hate it you did yeah but I I get
why you do it yeah I absolutely get why
you do it why do you want it why do you
want it at st. man so I'm asking bloody
why because a lot of people don't know
against property why I want to passive
income that's amazing awesome man why do
you like your job
yeah then why do you want to pay and it
makes them think Azmi what is it you
actually want i meant they call it the
rule of seven or something why why why
you know don't do it in a dickish way
what why mark was probably what i did to
you but yeah you want to keep keep
asking why you want to get new ideas for
yourself you'd have to do it with
someone else but think about okay what
what what is it that I want what what I
was talking to one of our members of
staff about this the other day what what
is it you want oh yeah have a think
about and then once you know what you
want then you go okay so I my business
to serve what I want yeah so it might be
that you want to work an hour a week and
live by a lake and go fishing and living
this peaceful in that mean what you want
I would hate that yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't want that I'd find that ball I
wouldn't even want to do that for a week
my brother would do that forever
there you go I wouldn't so you've got
different if you've got different goals
see there so therefore which is why you
should never try and tell someone what
they should do no no let them tell them
they should tell them say I need to know
what they want okay so a realistic goal
for did you see somebody that wants to
get property
yeah is it realistic for them to see
this time next year I'm gonna be a movie
you know
if the M scratch now yeah from the C
starting with ten grand 20 grand
they said they should say ten grand
think round in the bank yeah is it
realistic for somebody to see this ten
nation will be moving out well why is
that want to be a millionaire no no
forget about that I know no I'm not
gonna forget about it because that's you
know a lot it's realistic very nice say
they've not there why possible say
they've got the wire and they know what
they're going to know why they want to
do everything is it realistic for
somebody who's getting in property
within a minute with no knowledge but
they've got 15 10 15 grand in the bank
by this time next year to be a
millionaire from property it's possible
but I would say it's possible but it's
unlikely but is it realistic for them to
maybe get a couple of houses have a
really good understanding of property
and maybe have lots of friends within
property yeah yeah that's very possible
yeah so where would you set your goal so
that lets just take your average jewel
your average person where would you set
your goal would you set it somewhere in
the middle would you say that high end
or low well I'll be looking at two
things
another one would be time yeah and
number two will be money yeah so hey how
much time I have yeah and B how much
money I have right they've got say two
days a week and so they might be saying
I want to work I want to work two days
only in a year's time I want to be
working two days a week I don't want to
be on ten grand a month
yeah is that realistic yeah I think
that's a realistic cuz I've done it yeah
yeah don't realize that so that's right
and and most people would probably be
happy with that yeah forever yeah of
course they would yeah and they'd be
like perfect two days wait ten grand a
month amazing but what what my point I'm
trying to make is it's better to set
your goals a little bit higher than the
war mm-hmm I would rather like well hey
interesting interesting interesting
point I was a guy called you know
blessing yes yeah so he was talking
about having goals yeah and he just got
he climbs Kilimanjaro
every year and he says obviously the
goal is to get to the top the first time
he went he didn't manage it because he
went with his son his son became really
ill and they had to go back right so he
made about halfway and then had to go
back down and he was saying if all I was
focusing on was the goal which gets the
top yeah I would have thought it was a
total waste of money total waste of time
just been like I'd have come down it
felt really lovely about what a waste
rubbish right a lot of people have that
in life where they have their goal and
if they don't hit the goal it's like
what a waste but what you're saying is
it's about the journey
mm-hm and so there's a balance between
having a goal and enjoying the journey
yeah and he said I agree with cuz he
focused on the journey yeah he still got
a lot of lessons out of it he still
learned a lot he still enjoyed the time
of his son and obviously it got cut
short
I didn't made the goal but it was still
a great experience singers do you think
he'll hit that goal which girl get into
the top we've done every year since I
was I thought he was still on his path
together know is still ahead now he's on
his own what I mean is is he still like
I thought he was going back of year to
try and get for a long follow
although that he's made the top every
awesome but was the first time he went
oh but the point is is that it's there's
a balancing act between setting a high
goal and striving for the goal but the
same time enjoying the journey it's also
not being afraid to miss that goal
because it's better to miss a high goal
than hit a low go well if you're
prepared to enjoy the journey doesn't
matter if you miss the goal exactly
because you enjoy it I think some people
focus too much on hitting that goal and
then the the sacrifice other stuff which
is why this is the point about getting
your personal rehearsal goals because if
you if you just say to yourself I want
to be if you don't know what's important
to you then you'll might sacrifice
certain stuff in order to hit your goal
that you don't even know why you've set
the goal isn't this isn't this like the
reason why you see so many people that
made it then become depressed and become
sometimes like suicidal and think well a
lot of people become depressed once
they've made it because they've hit the
gold on the house live long just look
for I've sacrificed everything to get to
that goal Tyson Fury yes please gold
world champion and welcome with Campbell
champion put on ten stone got depressed
on drugs all sorts of stuff in his prime
a lot of people think he's made it yeah
but that was the problem because all the
whole life was living for that about and
he's done it now well sister well they
say that it's like astronauts are the
same they're gone
to get space and I'm back from space
they've done nothing well you got to
respect someone like Cristiano Ronaldo
okay why is he 34 years old he's won
everything and he's still strong he's
got lots of personal goals as well he's
got lots of stuff going on - he's a
massive cherry guy there's a lot of what
Denis lots of cherry one doesn't all get
anyone like that that's top of their
game and canteen Lewis Hamilton yeah
he's won the World Championship but
still wants more and more and and and
assuming that as long as they're
enjoying it as well as they go which I
believe certainly not Ronaldo it's for
example as long as he's enjoying it as
he goes that's perfect cuz you want to
get the right balance between wanting
more yeah but being satisfied of what
you've got I think you've got to enjoy
what you do though as well if if you
don't enjoy what you do it becomes a job
it becomes hard work mmm hey I know you
love what you do I love what I do so to
me working on my my goals is fun it's
enjoyable it's my favorite thing to do
see my house my favorite thing and a
part of that then comes to having a
mission yeah it's gotta be something
that's bigger than just you yeah if
you're on a mission it's bigger than
just you yeah that's where the magic
happens anyway number two goals number
two is tell the world yeah tell the
world you know you couldn't read my
messy handwriting like tell the world
tell the world so you've got to tell
people what you're doing yeah and
there's too many I like I'm guilty of
this so I'm not going to preach about it
cuz I didn't tell the world what I was
doing I was I was Samuels closet
investor do you know I mean so how did
he finally come out the closet I've come
out the closet with regarding this thing
what it's a reasonable question but it's
an innuendo which comes at the end of it
anyway right your render so yeah right
so you've got to tell the world you've
got to tell people what you're up to
because here's a question why do people
not do that because they're embarrassed
why they embarrassed because they're
gonna get hated upon this happened to me
man look I started telling everyone what
I do I started publicizing what I do I
start putting out there start telling
people on Facebook doing videos all
that's what stuff and then
you get the odd douchebag that comes
along and says ha ha look at you and I'm
like can I look at you you're broke do
not mean I don't care about them
forget the hairs forget that people are
gonna pull you down because they only
they're really trying to pull you down
people will be down and your family and
all sort of stuff how's your time then
we spoke about this before on this show
as well they're probably doing it
unintentionally because they don't know
any different
so that and I would say most if you if
you get in sort of not hate but if you
get in criticism from family members
it's probably they feel they're probably
doing it from a good place like oh it's
risky you're taking too many risks or
they probably feel they're giving you
advice like like we don't want you to
lose money or all that's what stuff and
I would say if it's coming from a family
it's not generally going to be are like
I art from our point of view where
they're actually just like trying to
bill it'll you and steal your dreams and
it's because they can't relate to you
yeah they can't relate because you've
changed quicker than them but you'll see
I've seen this with my friends where
I've gone on started doing really well
but they haven't
and then I've changed I've become a much
nicer much nicer person I've become a
bigger person not weight-wise but I've
become a bigger pair I was waiting for
the comment but I'm not in the joking me
although you opened up I was like I've
taken I've become bigger up here I've
become bigger in here because of my
journey and my friends whatever they
haven't they're still going to the pub
they're still at the same job they've
been in for five years they're not and
they're never going to change
but because I am changing they don't
like that and you get people talking
about you you know I don't care I don't
give them monkeys because do you know
what it's not their dream it's my dream
so don't you got to tell the world what
you're up to
when I told the world what I was they
don't care but you but you did care to
be given but I did I said where have you
been hated it
have you got through that try and do why
do you not care now it's never nice to
be it's not nice to be hated upon and I
don't get it as much as some people but
you get people criticizing you but you
know what I don't care because like when
you're making this what money I'm making
it makes it very easy to care
about what they hate in a bond so do you
know if someone criticizes you genuinely
are you making a decision that you don't
care or do you genuinely not care um no
I'm making a decision I don't care so
yes sometimes when you see when when you
hear that especially people that you
trusted it's when you have people that
you trust mmm and that you thought
actually they didn't they didn't say
that and then you hear things and it's
like do you know what listen you've got
problems you've got your fighting your
own battles I'm not going to judge you
and don't judge me so that we're not
listen this is this is so true I do talk
about this in my book right when you
accept what you're doing and you tell
the world what you're doing it is
amazing what happens things change and
yes you might lose some friends but
you'll get a lot of new friends like
I've now got afraid I'm no afraid I mean
that's all I like very good friends mean
same are very good friends so like the
friends are criticized and you their
family they're criticizing you do you
know what there's plenty of people out
there that will push you along and
support you and help I think one of the
reasons as well I agree with everything
you say only one of the reasons as well
is the people because especially if
they're new to it yeah they feel like a
bit of a fraud yeah yeah saying Island
property investor and they're like
Samuel tells the story of when and at
the crash course and he decides to give
up his job to be a property investor and
I older cousin was about seven years old
and Samuel was like oh I hear you were
he quit your job Simon was like yeah so
to her exam of 17 at the time to become
a property investor and something I was
like yeah and he's like so uh how many
properties she was like no and he's like
I felt like you know this yeah and
people are scared or like people are
gonna be like like who who do you think
you are saying your property especially
people that know you like your family
and stuff like that if you if you have
not done that before
yeah and then you soon aren't property
investor the hell do you think you are
but all the sorts of stuff so people are
scared the problem is the sort of people
that are saying that all will see that
to you are the sort of people that will
be happy
working 40 hours a week for the rest of
life yeah they're not the sort of
entrepreneurial type of mindset that
they're come from a position of a
freaking job hmm no I'm not criticizing
people that have a job I'm not I'm not
criticizing them but don't steal the
dreams of people that want to do better
than that
because at the end of the if you're in a
job I don't care what job you're in
you're not making yourself rich you're
making your boss rich I don't care what
job you are I don't care if you're I
don't care what you totally agree with
that I don't totally agree with that
football as a manager you know it again
it comes back to goals yeah if you're if
you love what you do and you work 40
hours a win you work for someone and
that no but realistically think abut you
might not want to be an entrepreneur
that's fine that's fine but you have
think if you're in a job you have to
understand that you're making some deals
which doesn't what job you're in you're
making some deals right necessarily
unless your doctor I suppose actually I
submit we wrong statement so unless you
like in a even if you work in a business
I know loads of small businesses where
the staff get paid more than the owners
do I don't agree let's just we'll cut
that I know what you mean and we've a
lot of companies that's the case but
yeah I think this is an issue I have
really weird especially some law I've
got I employ lots of people I don't see
them as just like that people often look
especially entrepreneurs and people they
look down on employees and they're like
oh I just need know they're not they're
doing what they want to do what they
think is right they might there's a lot
there's a lot of crap that comes with
you with a lot of stress but my point is
is that it might be more that want one
they want they might want you it's not
every once be an odd job but my point
most people don't steal the dreams of
people that do one thing entrepreneur
yeah but but don't don't
also don't steal the dreams of someone
who wants to be a doctor yeah or someone
that wants to be in the army or anything
yeah people have got to work out what
they want to do I don't think your
employees know you know you understand
my peers yeah yeah I'm what I'm saying
is did the people that generally it's
not just you by a lot
he tell you let me tell the master
cement knocks man can you imagine
Richard Branson ever hating on anybody
okay so people won't tell the world
because they're scared to get negative
comments and criticism do you know any
successful business person that gives
any criticism or hate or negativity to
anyone else turn to business Alan Sugar
really seen The Apprentice he's a right
dude but does he criticized all the
businesses are doing well does the Z
Chris has other people's business he
make criticizing people our own
apprentice
it's not a principle of damage but can
be my point being is Simon mentions us
you never get hate from people above you
and I'm not state employees or people
that are working on below you but it's
always people are trying to bring you
back down to their label cuz they've not
stay it though and it's true you look on
any of the negative comments that we see
online you start looking into the people
that are doing it they're working in a
job or that they've not got an
entrepreneurial mind because if you had
an entrepreneurial man you wouldn't be
hating on people I think the key pushing
people out the key and helping them is
that you just is just encourage other
people and whatever they want to drag
that don't try and drag over people down
what do you think it bugs me and we've
had it with the podcast people hating
upon the podcast why do you go out your
way to hate upon something like what
sort of negative life do you live that
you have to hit upon something how crap
is your life that you have to mourn
about other people get grip man yeah a
lot of people waste right number three
friends yep big one a lot of people know
this the five people you spend the most
time with and you end up being up the
net result of the yeah of those people
so if you spend your time with five rich
people you'll be the six if you spend
your time five negative people you'll be
the six yeah and and it's really it's
about environment I think so and about
context can I just see here I've got one
thing that I found with the Academy
their Academy program is forget the
investment take the investment away from
it it is the doors it opens and the
people you get introduced to and it's
the people you're socializing with
because you socialize with successful
people love the rate the same mindset
that are there to say come on man let's
get along let's see what we can do it
helped
and it goes back to a previous subject
when you talk people it's not getting
pulled back by people yeah I said I said
that to the Economist the last week yeah
exactly what you just said I said I
encourage you guys to I know you're
doing it already
do it more yeah meet once a week go what
they arranged a little dinner on the
night and I was like who did that you
give her a hand that's amazing
you know you that's the sort of stuff
you guys should be doing because you
know how many of you are surrounded by
negativity you know your environment is
so so key because the thing is you've
got five percent of your brain or ten
percent your brain and that small amount
is conscious mm-hmm the rest of it is
all your subconscious and that I do and
you say you're going to see unconscious
you're this were you in Vegas the rest
of is all your subconscious brains and
your subconscious is so affected by your
environment yeah and so affected by you
bow-bow all all the stuff around you in
the decisions and and most of the
decisions you make are subconscious and
then your thoughts and everything like
that so if you can put yourself in a
positive environment way around positive
people and you having positive thoughts
and positive influences it is so good
it's the feeling it gives you like when
you're select even just things like like
when we are all together we laugh we
have a joke we get along when you spend
there doing that you go away feeling
pumped yeah you go away feeling happy
you were a feeling that was an awesome
day like a crash course yeah people like
seeing about high fives don't like high
fives and when you go to when you go to
the crash course come on we feeling do
this you can wait in a jar refresh the
environment yeah it's the environment
and the academy is the same people
already care to me they come to the
events due to events every month to come
to all the events even have been to the
same event before people are coming back
because they want to be in that
environment and they come away they're
like yeah I know when I first joined the
Academy that's why I was come to all the
vane yeah so you should come to every
single I've been that every single I've
been to every single crash course since
I joined the Academy you think it's more
crash courses than me
yep and I do you know why I go I go
because you're around like-minded people
you're on people that wanted that want
you to succeed yeah and like it's not it
doesn't become a competition it doesn't
be like it's not like
oh he's done this and after night it's
not like that it's like yeah I've done
that how can I help you do the same or
have what can we do that gets you there
do you not mean so if you're struggling
you're with people that can help you
yeah yeah and and that's what I love
that and you it's just the invite the
environment environment so and I'll all
like Simon was really strict upon like
sort of any sort of downbeat negativity
in the Academy don't we don't nip it in
the bud fellas
oh I hate negativity yeah I I don't
watch the news people you know what's
the news just depress it it's depressing
I don't want to be getting up in the
morning and starting my day yeah
listening to a bomb I don't know burgers
Church they're like all this happened
this week and right now and against
thoughts mindset right now the world is
the safest yeah the set people living
the longest people having less diseases
less likely to get killed less like all
it's the safest it's ever been in
history you wouldn't know it because all
we talk about is the negative and so
cause negativity cells how many times do
you see a positive story on the BBC News
at six never never you never it's almost
this person this person that's all
negativity rubbish it's all borman's for
King and it's just been negativity
negativity negativity and it's you think
they do that because they want I think
they do it because they want people to
live a negative life I do
I don't want control they want control
they want people to be scared realize
that they can't achieve their dreams I
think all goes in this about money a
nice n easy busy cells yeah a negative
yourselves but it's not great it's not
great so friends that's good what about
number four number four is on learn yep
so this is a bit of an unusual one
because normally think of of learning
and unlearn what do you might think of
it like a painting so you've got a
painting all right and somebody's
already had a go at doing it and I
messed up badly
yeah you've then got to over and try and
correct it whereas if you had a blank
canvas you could do a nice painting
mm-hmm
so the problem is a lot of people that
are maybe a little bit older generally
well
they've got they've got habits they've
got beliefs of how things are done
sometimes you have to brainwash them a
wash their brain and get rid of all that
old clutter and get rid of the old ways
of doing things like for instance I know
a property investor he's he's an
accidental landlord he all his mortgages
are through his high street bank and
it's like made you know there's so much
more creative ways of doing it yeah but
he won't have it he still goes to the
Halifax to get his a investment mortgage
a lot of a lot of it is like the
education system the work that so when
the education system was set up it was
designed to and especially in America I
remember I've tried I'm trying remember
this is accurate as I can but don't
quote me any of this but they were
basically sort of saying that the
education system was designed to keep
the they don't want it they don't want
to create successful people they want to
create workers to serve the rich and all
the education system designs create work
because it was designed like factories
are the bells and all sorts of stuff and
so we want to teach them enough they'll
be useful yeah but we don't we don't
want them being anybody's we don't want
them being we just want to control them
and and we want to just get them through
the mill and that it really pissed me
off why do you think I agree we yeah
this was in they actually it wasn't like
this was just in the back of their heads
this was typed up in there like you know
their objectives and stuff and that was
what the education education system was
based on I reckon that's why they have
their car our morning tea break 10 to
10:15 yeah in a lunchtime 12 to 12:30 in
an afternoon tea brick mm-hmm what's
that steak factories and they did this
block that and they did a test on on
children right so I think it was the
test when the kids were age four and it
was a creative test I've seen this seen
this yeah to test how creative they were
when they were four and ninety-eight
percent of them were genius level right
they then did the same test when they
were like six after a couple years of
schooling it dropped to like I can't
remember the percentages have a like 50%
then again when there were a 30% and
more talking about 12 it was like 5% or
something they're just drilling it bang
bang bang
kick
or out of you and as a parent I've got
like a three old and a foil I'm like do
I want to be sending my kids through
this and through this system it's hard
isn't it at the same time
like what it's hard but that me you
everyone we're all getting drummed in
the same stuff all the way through here
Walker yeah be a worker sweetie that's
what you that's what the schools are it
really is so frustrating that we do not
teach our children basic money no money
management financial literacy yeah we
don't teach them any of this sort of all
we teach them is how to be good remember
us yep that's it it's like fill in the
blanks read this remember this they
don't learn to think yeah it's it's all
about it's all it is is it's just it's
just filling the max remember remember
remember remember this remember that
listen
English is really important Master I'm
not saying I'm not saying I know I know
what you mean really important but we're
not teaching them about being Orangeburg
we're not teaching them about managing
money we're not teach them life skills
just do not get just do not get taught
and and also there's a lot of like old
older sort of school investors and that
that they're set in their ways of how to
finance things and we just need to get
that if they want to get really creative
about things and what what the the
systems that sorry the media and that
teaches us a better thing it's just a
lot of this wrong but even even the
system of when we finished studying at
school yeah we stopped learning like
what's that where since when's amazing
it's take anything and it's amazing how
many people will spend thirty thousand
pounds equal to uni but they won't spend
a little bit of money on educating
himself properly on entrepreneurship and
things all time isn't even a to be money
yeah they might put time into download
books affordable the dirt the person it
does baffle me completely bad for me so
you have to make sure you unlearn things
guys if you learn all the crap that
you've learned this
wrong way yeah the stuff that the
government is sort of force an
appointment I would say the biggest
thing my only really me it's prepare to
be coachable prepare to change don't be
stuck in your ways
don't be and the older you get the
harder it gets so you're completely
completely just so used to doing yes sir
right and the other thing is is if you
want to learn a new skill learn it from
something that's doing that skill like
if you want to learn to swim you gonna
get something that's good swimmin be
humble yeah to learn be prepared to
change your views don't be stuck don't
be thinkin with us how I've always done
it just be be open be open minded which
is one thing I think we are better at
now I think that the the the new
generations can move through a very open
mind yeah in many ways which is good
right no a five become best friends with
agents and right move yep cut that can't
see much more than that just to make
right move your best friends right move
your best friend it's yeah it's one all
that it's quite sad yeah it's quite sad
nice please what am I
obviously instead of looking at rubbish
on the internet look at right move if
you're looking to get in probably
embarrassing you should be looking at
houses constantly in the game should be
in the game keep yourself in the game so
once you've found your patch and you've
got your area you should be just keep in
touch with the agents don't be that
person that never calls them and then
suddenly pop up and your morning why
they're not bringing any deals just go
in now if you're it if you happen to be
in the area just go ahead and say hi
have you got any deals the speaker what
if you go if you've got anything
available and the more they see you the
more they know you the more likely
they're gonna come to you and say hey
Russell I've got this fantastic deal I
don't that's not on the market yeah you
interested because they know that you're
serious
yeah I'm also right moving there's a lot
of hidden gems on Rightmove understand
how it works and I'm gonna have to
credit you I think you're one of the
best people I think of that does this
agent yeah with everything we've we've
keeping yourself yeah with all of them
but with this one we've keeping yourself
not only bad at the others dig yourself
a hole here
you do you particularly good at this one
yeah keeping him with the agents I mean
you know the agents and all the areas
you like oh yeah this and I know this
and they showed me this and they told me
listen oh hi how'd you go
very good I've got a lot of networking
and yeah they called me the networking
ninja yeah where was I I I'm in my
station I'm not as patient I'm not the
networking not these like this is not
fair I was just kiddin the is it's
imperative and my book it was a whole
chapter about keeping yourself in the
game the book the book there's a whole
chapter about keeping yourself in the
game
yeah and with agents or stuff whole
chapter yeah so that's good so they're
there five top tips for beginners
looking to get into property I hope
that's helpful
it's now time for this
[Music]
okay so in the news this week
interesting article haven't got masses
triple about it but I just thought we'd
share it basically there's been talk of
Facebook getting into property investing
as in not buying property in the UK but
having like selling houses basically on
Facebook what they can market like we've
got a marketplace like me for yeah but
like so they're sort of quiver lot of
like right Mughal soup or whatever which
would be awesome I think I'd be
phenomenal yeah everyone's on Facebook
the talk it the talk is is it going to
like you know damage like right move and
people like that but it's well I'm sure
the right me of directors do but then
they need to move with the times don't
they yeah it's good for the consumer
competition yeah but if Facebook got on
that it would be very very interesting
be very very interesting because you
also probably get a lot of direct
Devender stuff and there yeah if the the
open up so the the vendors can put it
directly on Facebook for sale and make
our feast
if I get do then the agents will be not
like it as well it's gonna be it's
fascinating so I but I just thought it
could we what is base report more on it
when in all see it comes to fruition but
that's going to be phenomenal I think a
very very interesting right so now time
to answer your questions so here we go
are you ready for some questions
yeah gone hit me what's up guys
sup Liam would love you to talk about
social housing you used to live in a
social housing house did you know yeah
twelve years ago so what your views on
it I didn't okay so we but we but we use
the council right to buy scheme to buy
my wife's capitalized yeah okay so cool
would you think of social housing I
don't think much about it to be honest I
haven't got masses to say I'm more in
the private sector yeah I'm much more on
private sector Moni ever link for social
housing was we bought rx counselor made
a killing on it
and also if you've got an opinion on
repossession we did talk about
repossession didn't we actually argued
about it didn't wish I found out I'm not
sure if it was on camera law I was it
not I think we didn't that never meet
the final car okay because I think you
punched me did i okay well moving on
that move
well I run a Richards hour Buster's
asked a question that link to me
punching you but not may has Samuel stop
beating up Alastair
yeah I've recovered how how did it feel
it was funny is that the real reason why
you don't wanna live with him
you might jump on you in the middle of
the night I started tacking it but no
Samuel is cool do you know comment no
why just because I want to hear you
comment now I wanna hear you thinking
what you thinking I'll tell you
off-camera tell me on camera no tell me
now all right Nick turn the camera off
all right cameras off corn no not gonna
happen the camera is not there's no red
light or anything I can see it we'll see
what the camera into the camera I'm not
saying it disappeared I'm saying it's
off move on okay last one yeah as you
have for Matt it's a good one go Anna
okay
when would you advise for and against a
limited company structure good we answer
this question all the time and Gerald
Lee just put his heart and soul into
that question great question they're all
great it's a great aggression buddy and
listen we're not here to give tax advice
so you need to come speak to your
accountant about that personally if I if
it was me I would be putting everything
for a limited company two reasons tax
benefits and also you ring-fence
yourself so you're not personally liable
so what's the negative the negative is
your accounts are public bit harder to
and mortgages are a little bit harder to
get and you may pay much more interest
but Gerald honestly go and speak to your
accountant get a good property
accountant who will advise you to
explain my little situation once they've
explained once you've disclosed your
situation now because we don't know your
situation you might have half a million
quid in the bank or I'm at 100 million
in the bank we don't know so everyone's
situation is different when it comes to
accounting advice so but would you say
rule of thumb rule of thumb I would
see a limited company all the way um but
that's not official accountancy advice
going to you on accountant but it's all
on just to get you're not an official
account no I'm not asking a few but nope
not an official accountant eager he's
not was that the last ones like a grand
tour on that bombshell bomb on that
massive disappointment yeah it is time
to end
guys thank you so much for watching if
you don't want to watch this on youtube
you can subscribe to us on Apple
podcasting 1 just listening while you're
driving home from work on a Monday you
want to just listen in you know feel
free to do that and we will see you next
week
[Applause]
Oh